now I asked you at the beginning to pull
up in desmos so I want you if you
haven't already to do that now
because these guys here I want us to
look at these we've done some algebra
that's nice but I want to see what's
going on because it's an important
visual relationship between a function
and its inverse that I want to get out
so here's what we'll do once you've got
that open there and I'm going to take a
second to catch up but communis graph
the first example can you input the
first function and also input its
inverse can you do that change it both
those for me you should have written
down - I'm gonna pull this
hmm so if you don't have the equations
down it's three X minus one is the first
lengthy original and then 1/3 of X plus
one right got it
waiting now what I'd love you to do is
because I want you to not worry too much
about the graphing of it that's why I
got you to pull up in desmos but I would
love you once you're looking at this
draw like a rough version of this in
your book so that when we read you know
we've closed this down you'll be able to
look back at your notes you'd be like oh
that's what we were talking about so it
doesn't have to be beautifully accurate
but it does need to show basically
what's going on here just press the
divide button it should give you a
fraction I think we'll do it all right
yep cool or on your keyboard the yeah
this backslash I think it's the
backslash I never remember which ones
back and which ones forward I think it's
the backslash will give you a division
okay that within our it's the it's the
increasing function there anyway it
doesn't matter
I find the divided button okay do you
have this on your screen
yeah okay now one shot it what I want
you to notice is these two functions
right one is the func the original it's
the green one for me right and the other
one is the inverse okay now before I
sort of move off of these do you notice
that the the whole green is the inverse
of the whole purple but you also have
within the function itself see how
you've got a minus one and then a plus
one you're like are there they undo each
other right and you can this is why I
wrote this as a third rather than is
dividing by three that multiply by three
and that a third they also undo each
other right so you sort of get this
shape happening right now what I'd love
you to add onto there
just like start a new line and all I
want you to write in is the single
letter X can you do that for me right
just type in the letter X
now did you notice there's a
relationship between the function which
I've got in green its inverse and also
this dotted line y equals x right you'll
be able to see that relationship if
unlike me which I cannot do with the
projector if you pick up your screen and
turn it 45 degrees can you do it so that
this y equals x turn it around so that y
equals x line my one which is dotted so
it's straight up and down can you see
the relationship between the function
and its inverse right so you can just
turn your head if you like okay and
that's all I can do with this thing so
do you notice this is symmetrical isn't
it right y equals x is kind of like your
line of symmetry and then to go from one
to the other it sort of flips over yeah
okay now you can see I've also prepared
this earlier that was only the first
function in inverse can you do the
second function and its inverse it was X
cubed plus 2 and there's also the cube
root of x minus 2 you might not know
where the cube root button is so when
you go to when you go and get your
keyboard down here if you go over to the
right-hand side two functions and then
if you click oh sorry I'm sort of like
right there we go
if you go over to miscellaneous here you
get this guy right over here on the
right hand side you can see there's a
square root it's actually a radical sign
and then there's like this is not
high-resolution enough but that's an N
you can pick any root that you like not
just the square root you can put a 3 in
there and it'll give you the cube root
okay so go ahead find that function and
then you'll be able to draw this as well
you may like to get rid of those two
original functions because you're going
to your graphs gonna get super busy
super fast but maybe just leave y equals
x there
okay guys I know you're still drawing
that's okay I will give you some time to
continue drawing but can I ask you to
put your pens down momentarily and look
up because I want to try and unpack some
of the stuff that's going on here and
why it's happening okay and then you
will be able to continue going right he
just pens out of hands for minute look
up just waiting on okay great so what's
going on here what have we just
determined well we've said and I've
covered it but you've got it there in
your notes if you want to go from a
function to its inverse then you can do
something with algebra you can take all
your X's and swap them for Y's and also
take all your wires and swap them for
X's right that will give you the
equations that you want but if you know
what the picture looks like you know we
spent a lot of time say here's a
function and then tell me what the
square root of that thing looks like or
tell me what the absolute value of that
looks like right if you want to look at
it visually to go from which one is the
original function here it's the red one
yeah there's X cubed plus 2 if you take
this function right and you have y
equals x as well then the inverse is a
reflection right you can see it
reflecting across that line if you sort
of turn your head it's like oh it's sort
of like a what is that it's like a
radish looking thing or a VARs or or
like an upside down poem chess piece
from like anyway so yeah you get the
idea right now the important thing for
you understand is why is this happening
like it's not just oh that's nice but
there's a reason for it right I want you
to think about some of the points that
you've got here for instance like this
point right here what are its
coordinates this one here it's 0 comma 2
that's the original one right but then
algebraically what we said was
everywhere you see an X you swap it for
a Y and everywhere you've got a Y you
swap it for an X so what this turns into
when you think about the inverse is not
0 comma 2 but 2 comma 0 and I see where
that is there it is right so in other
words this guy what it does is it kind
of like jumps over it goes whoop over
there right pick another point that
looks roughly just I want right that's
actually no it's not roughly I think
it's exactly no maybe it's not that's
gonna be 3 no sorry that's one and a
half actually one and a half all the way
up to what's that
five and a half-ish okay one and a half
five and a half what is that converting
into well instead off I'll write it down
instead of one and a half five and a
half I'm going to switch right so yeah
five and a half one and a half now where
is that that looks like it's going to be
here right should you see it went from
over here and it sort of went across you
see the line that it sort of creates
right now this is happening for every
single point on the graph right this is
the original one the straight lines
right actually should have done this
first because it has nicer points okay
every single point like three eight
moves over to its inverse point where
you swap the X and the y right
everything moves over except for one
point there's one point on the original
and exactly one that doesn't move
anywhere which one is it yeah very good
where'd they meet right now actually I
kind of lied I said it doesn't go
anywhere but it does a half half goes to
it goes to a half half that's why it's
exactly where it is right so if you go
back to the cubic you can see the same
thing happens right see this guy down
here I don't know what is that negative
one and a half negative one half ish
right the X corner and the y corner are
the same so when it flips over you just
stay there does that make sense
so that is why this reflection is
happening across now underneath I'm
going to mute this now underneath where
you wrote this algebraically right this
is what we with the algebra but then we
graphed it and we saw visually visually
there is also a relationship right
namely that f of X if you start from
that you take a reflection across y
equals x to get the inverse right so I
can say I'll write it in the right
colors the inverse f of X is a
reflection of the original function is a
reflection
what's it a reflection across again what
line y equals x right y equals x that's
the place where reflecting across
okay mm-hmm stay put okay now one more
thing to say before I let you guys have
a bit of a play with this and you can
see over on the right hand side I've
written in excess 2h this part that
we've just sort of covered will take you
through this first three questions at
the top later on we're going to need to
learn some more stuff to do the rest of
that exercise but you remember right at
the beginning I said we're mainly going
to focus on functions relations kind of
hang on for the ride right but you guys
already know a whole bunch of relations
and you can do exactly the same thing
here okay I'm just going to show you
this one and then you can have a play
with it okay we bring this back down
today there we go
reflexes okay it's got a spot that it
likes I'm gonna find it eventually just
a okay so there it's happened to me
before okay so for example this guy yeah
Algy this guy here right this is not a
function is it what is it that makes it
a relation by the way yeah there was a
test that we use we call it the vertical
line test because when you take said
vertical line if you can put it
somewhere on the graph and it hits more
than once in this case twice you're like
well there's a point of hits twice
actually there's a whole bunch of them
you like up it fails not a function okay
but if we take this right here's x
squared plus y minus two or squared what
does that tell you by the way that left
hand side what information do you get
from that
we'll get the radius from the right hand
side what do we get from the left hand
side it's the center which in this case
is its it's got our coordinates right so
it's 0 - yeah that's where the center is
so there's the center the radius is of
course look look there's a 4 there so
that's 2 squared so that's the radius of
2 right what happens when you swap
everything around I want you to think
about it for a second
you can see here I've done the algebra
but I don't wanna show it to you just
yet what do you predict will happen
because you did this already for a few
times you saw the visual
fact right if you put on the other
circle there yes right
do you see does it match with what you
expected you see if you turn your head
and you're like oh there's the
reflection right and also there are
there in this case not one but two spots
that don't don't go anywhere right see
there's the origin 0 0 just becomes 0 0
and that's um that's 1 1 right and it
just becomes itself ok so this isn't in
this is a relation and it's inverse
relation we can do this they're just not
gonna be mainly our focus which spot
also I know you're exactly right that's
2 - I was just looking at that grid
lines and getting confused ok